Bolivia y Chile son el Pimpinela de Latino
América. Sí, es cierto, comparten frontera.
Pero no podían tener más diferencias entre ellos. Bolivia es uno de los países más
pobres del continente mientras que Chile es uno de los más ricos. Bolivia es uno de
los abanderados del socialismo indígena
y Chile es considerado como el Mordor del
neoliberalismo absoluto. Y, por si fuera poco, estos dos países llevan años con disputas
territoriales.
Sin embargo, hay una cosa que tienen en común
estos países. Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik...
estamos hablando del ORO BLANCO.
No ese oro blanco. Me estoy refiriendo al
LITIO. El litio es el metal que se utiliza
para fabricar las baterías de vuestros teléfonos móviles, vuestros ordenadores portátiles
o los coches eléctricos que, muy probablemente, terminen inundando las ciudades y carreteras
de todo el mundo.
Lo llaman el nuevo petróleo. El metal más
ligero de la tabla periódica. Su valor se
ha multiplicado por 10 en las últimas dos
décadas. Y su demanda no para de crecer. Entre el 60 y el 80% de las reservas conocidas
están en lo que ya se conoce como el triángulo del litio. Una zona que comprende parte de
Argentina, Bolivia y Chile. En estos países,
el litio no sólo es abundante sino que además
está muy cerca de la superficie y es muy
fácil de extraer. Dicho de otra forma, esta
zona puede convertirse rápidamente en el
nuevo Arabia Saudita.
"La forma en la que se encuentra... se encuentra en desiertos de sal, lo que se conoce como
salares. Y eso es muy distinto que sacar el litio de rocas duras. Es mucho más barato
y más eficiente."
De estos tres países, Bolivia es el más
afortunado. El llamado SALAR DE UYUNI tiene
entre dos y tres veces más reservas de litio
que los yacimientos de Argentina o Chile.
Por otra parte, Chile es el único país
que ya cuenta con empresas mineras nacionales.
Sin embargo, la que parece estar acaparando toda la atención de los inversores internacionales
es Argentina. Y Bolivia, pese a tener los
mayores yacimientos de litio, es el país
que menos mineral produce.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Qué está ocurriendo
en Bolivia? ¿Por qué nadie quiere explotar
sus minas de litio? ¿Y por qué Chile podría
seguir la misma dirección? Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas. Pero antes... vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
"¿UN NUEVO POTOSÍ?"
Los que lleváis tiempo suscritos a VisualPolitik ya sabéis que tener muchos recursos naturales
no es sinónimo de ser rico. En Bolivia lo
saben muy bien. Este país tiene todas las
materias primas que os podéis imaginar:
litio, plata, gas natural... y sin embargo,
es uno de los países más pobres de todo
Latinoamérica. Durante siglos, las minas
de plata de Potosí financiaron toda clase
de gastos por parte de la corona española
durante el siglo 16 y 17. De hecho, todavía en España decimos "esto vale un Potosí"
cuando queremos decir que algo es muy caro.
Sin embargo, los nativos bolivianos vieron
pocos beneficios de la extracción de este
metal y millones murieron bajo condiciones
de trabajo extremas. Por eso, es razonable que el Gobierno de Evo Morales tenga tanto
recelo de las empresas extranjeras que quieren venir a explotar el litio.
Además, no nos engañemos. El auténtico
negocio no está en la extracción de materias
primas sino en la industria que viene después.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en el momento
el que hacemos este vídeo, la tonelada de
litio cotiza por, alrededor de los 9000 USD.
Sin embargo, si tomamos ese litio en bruto
y lo convertimos en baterías para teléfonos
móviles, podemos conseguir unos ingresos de entre 1.5 y 5 millones de dólares. Por
supuesto, esto es un cálculo muy aproximado y habría que tener en cuenta otro tipo de
gastos. Pero la comparativa es muy ilustrativa.
Y eso explica esta noticia.
¡Pero no sólo eso! En Bolivia, el litio
está nacionalizado. Eso significa que, si
eres una empresa minera y quieres operar en suelo boliviano, tienes que asociarte con
el gobierno y montar una nueva compañía
público-privada. Esta nueva empresa cobra
dinero por extraer el mineral, abrir la mina,
instalar las máquinas, etc... PERO el litio
que se saque de la explotación pertenece
al Gobierno Boliviano, que es el único que
tiene derecho a venderlo.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué Bolivia necesita
empresas extranjeras para extraer sus recursos?
¿No pueden hacerlo ellos mismos?
Lo cierto es que no. La minería de hoy en
día ya no tiene nada que ver con el clásico
señor que va con un pico y una pala a picar piedra. Hoy en día se utilizan máquinas
de alta tecnología y, sobretodo, ingenieros muy bien preparados. En un país tan pobre
como Bolivia, estas cosas escasean. Y desarrollar tu propio sector empresarial llevaría décadas.
Por eso es tan importante contar con empresas que ya saben cómo explotar el litio, tienen
las herramientas y el personal cualificado.
Y por eso, incluso Evo Morales, que ya sabéis
que no es un gran amigo de las multinacionales,
ha tenido que salir buscar inversores.
¿Pero cuál es el problema? Pues que como decíamos antes, el litio de Bolivia está
nacionalizado. Es decir, que esas empresas que quisieran invertir en el país, sólo
pueden sacar beneficios por asociarse con el gobierno. De esos beneficios, tienen que
pagar un impuesto minero del 37,5%, el más alto de toda la región. Por si esto fuera
poco, según el Banco Mundial, Bolivia está entre los 50 países donde es más difícil
hacer negocios, al mismo nivel que Sierra
Leona.
En otras palabras... si tuvierais que invertir vuestro dinero en litio... ¿Os iríais
a Bolivia o buscaríais otro país?
Pues bien, eso explica que aunque Bolivia
tenga los mayores recursos de litio, sea el
país que menos mineral está explotando
hasta la fecha.
Fijaros bien en la gráfica porque el país
que lidera la explotación del oro blanco
en este momento en el que hacemos el vídeo
es AUSTRALIA. Y esto es llamativo si tenemos en cuenta que los yacimientos de este país
son 4 veces más pequeños que los de Bolivia. Y además, los sueldos australianos son seis
veces más altos que los bolivianos. Es decir, que no se trata de una cuestión de trabajo
barato sino de buenas o malas políticas
económicas.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque este no es el único problema! No olvidéis que la
ambición de Evo Morales es que Bolivia se convierta en un líder de fabricación de
baterías. Pero ¿Cómo puede conseguir
esto sin empresas extranjeras que se instalen
en el país? Sí, ya, el Gobierno puede
pagar la construcción de una fábrica.
Por supuesto que puede hacerlo. Pero la tecnología, las patentes y el conocimiento sobre cómo
se hacen las baterías es propiedad de empresas como Panasonic, Samsung o Tesla. Sin la colaboración
de estas compañías, Bolivia necesitaría
años de I+D+i para poder competir en el
mercado internacional.
Y ahora os preguntaréis ¿Qué están
haciendo en Chile?
CHILE, TRAS LOS PASOS DE BOLIVIA
Durante años, Chile ha sido reconocido como la Disneylandia del libre mercado. Concretamente,
su sector minero era uno de los más libres que existía en todo el mundo. Hablamos de
un país cuyo principal sector económico
es la explotación del cobre. Y por eso,
en 1981, la dictadura de Pinochet sacó una ley, la llamada "Ley Minera", que permitía
que las empresas privadas pudieran tener el 100% de la propiedad de una mina. Como os
podéis imaginar, esta legislación disparó
la inversión extranjera en el país. De
repente llegaron montones de empresas como la australiana BHP Billiton o la suiza XTrata.
Y ya sé lo que estáis pensando... que
todas estas multinacionales saquearon el país
entero dejándolo sumido en la pobreza ¿Verdad?
Bueno... pues os equivocáis.
Todas estas empresas canadienses, suizas o australianas llegaron a explotar el cobre,
sí. Pero también ayudaron a financiar
muchas empresas nuevas, con sede en Santiago
de Chile, trabajadores chilenos y presidentes
chilenos. Hablamos de compañías como Minera
Escondida o Antofagasta PLC.
En realidad, gracias a esta oleada de inversiones
extranjeras, Chile cuenta ahora con un sector minero de importancia internacional. De hecho,
muchos de esos ingenieros que faltan en Bolivia, viven en los mejores barrios de Santiago de
Chile. Y eso significa que, desde el primer
momento, los chilenos partían con ventaja
para liderar esta carrera por el litio. Sin
embargo, en 2016, la presidenta chilena, Michelle
Bachelet, dejó claro que el litio va a ser
un caso especial.
"Una de las primeras definiciones que adoptamos fue acoger el llamado de la comisión de
reafirmar el carácter estratégico del
litio, propiedad de todos los chilenos y chilenas,
y mantener su condición de material no concesible"
En otras palabras, que el Gobierno de Chile
quiere seguir la misma política que el Gobierno de Bolivia. Pero con una diferencia. En este
caso, el país si que cuenta con la tecnología y el personal necesario para poder explotar
sus recursos de forma eficiente. Por supuesto, muchas empresas extranjeras que estaban dispuestas
a invertir en el país han perdido todo el
interés. Pero la economía chilena ya cuenta
con sus propias compañías. A eso hay que sumarle que, hasta 2014, los otros dos países
que conforman este triángulo del litio,
Argentina y Bolivia, eran mucho peores para
la inversiín. En el país de los ciegos,
el tuerto es el rey. Así que Chile jugaba
con ventaja.
Hasta ahora. La gran sorpresa ha sido ARGENTINA.
Mientras Chile y Bolivia han optado por nacionalizar
sus yacimientos de litio y hacer todo lo posible por ahuyentar a las empresas extranjeras,
Argentina, con el gobierno de Macri, está
adoptando una política muy distinta... y
está acaparando la atención de todos los
inversores internacionales en detrimento de
Chile y Bolivia.
Pero de eso vamos a hablar en las próximas semanas. Si no os lo queréis perder, ya
sabéis... suscribíos al canal.
Mientras tanto, ahora la pregunta es... ¿Realmente creéis que Bolivia y Chile serán capaces
de aprovechar los beneficios del litio? ¿O
será Argentina quien gane esta carrera?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios.
Y si queréis conocer más en profundidad
todos los cambios que ha llevado a cabo Evo
Morales en Bolivia, haced click en este otro vídeo donde Couto os lo explica.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un abrazo y hasta
pronto!